todos los extremadamente importante es
la primera azul porque fue esa ciudad
proclamada como califato por abu omar
al-baghdadi en 2014 y tal vez la ciudad
que más sufrió de todos estos terror que
vivió durante dos años de índice allí
había una gran presencia de cristianos
históricamente no solamente de
cristianos sino de otras minorías que
habitan en este país que tuvieron que
oír o que fueron perseguidas o se les
obligó a convertirse al islám así que la
llegada del papa hasta esa planta esa
explanada de las iglesias una de ellas
extremadamente destruida como altamira
la cual por ciento pues es un gran
mensaje en el cual dijo que había que
convivir y que la religión o la repetir
lo que había dicho ayer la religión no
puede ser utilizada como un mecanismo de
violencia y también le pidió a los
cristianos que se quedaran que se
quedaran en esta zona del mundo y
también les pidió que perdonara que
perdonará a los que habían hecho daño
que la única manera que pueden
permanecer en estos países
catalina ya usted mencionaba algunos
pero cuáles fueron esos otros mensajes
destacados que el papá francisco dejó
durante esta última jornada
fue muy interesante lo que dijo bien
para curso cuando les hablo de lo que
hablaba ahora del perdón de la necesidad
de perdonar a nosotros para seguir
viviendo
porque lo que pasó en caracas y también
en mosúl fue que muchos de esos
cristianos se sintieron traicionados por
sus vecinos o por los pueblos vecinos
musulmanes que informaron a isis o que
les dieron la espalda cuando ellos
fueron atacados no toms hubo gente que
los ayudó de que los protegió pero la
mayoría así que el mensaje del papa es
la única manera para convivir juntos y
para poder permanecer es quedarse y
perdonar a quienes les hicieron daño
pero también les dijo que se queden
especialmente a los jóvenes hablo le
dijo que había
que había esperanza que por favor
lucharan y es que para la iglesia
católica es muy importante que los
cristianos permanezcan no solamente en
irak junto a esa parte del mundo de aquí
son ingente originarios aquí inicia el
cristianismo y lo que han pasado con la
violencia y con especialmente con el
ascenso de estos grupos islámicos
extremistas como al qaeda en su momento
y si es que muchos de estos cristianos
habían decidido emigrar del país y
también lo hacen los jóvenes por las
situaciones económicas así que este de
esta visita del papa fue un grito para
que se queden y para que la comunidad
cristiana siga existiendo como parte
importante de esta comunidad y en un
respeto él dijo que todos estos países
necesitaban de estas minorías porque
hacían parte de de su tejido social así
que con este mensaje terminado la visita
del papa ya ya viene camino
y mañana regresará a roma